I've been talking with you for years at
this point about the completely utterly
destructive nature of Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu's presence
in Israeli politics this is a guy who
I've been saying for years just has to
go and there are many impediments to
peace in the israeli-palestinian
conflict as many of you in the audience
know I've not been shy about naming all
of them but Benjamin Netanyahu is one of
them this is not a guy who wants peace
in the sense that it doesn't benefit him
politically to have serious discussions
that might lead to a peace agreement and
I know there are plenty of other parties
who also don't benefit from peace but
we're talking about Benjamin Netanyahu
today Netanyahu is heavily aligned with
the most extreme religious elements of
the Israeli political sphere almost
everything that he does is
counterproductive to the goal of a path
to a long lasting and permanent peace
agreement and he benefits from the
status quo not being that and being one
of threats and being on the verge of
something all the time so we heard
yesterday Benjamin Netanyahu is going to
make a big announcement it is just going
to be a huge huge huge announcement that
he is going to be making by the way a
week before the election in Israel how
exciting and of course I assumed it
would be some horrible thing or some
brazen distraction of some kind and it
was Benjamin Netanyahu's big
announcement is that if Israelis reelect
him he will take more land he will annex
pieces of the West Bank much to the
pleasure of people associated with
Donald Trump's administration here in
the United States and in this particular
case Benjamin Netanyahu was talking
about the Jordan Valley and the northern
Dead Sea the Trump administration of
course was asked officially do you
support this idea they simply said our
policy has not changed but intimating
that pretty clearly they're not going to
get in the way of Ben
Netanyahu doing this if he is indeed
reelected so this is a very brazen
tactic from Netanyahu we've seen this
before he's worried about losing he's
not polling well it would be great for
him to lose by the way so he has done
what he always does he has concocted
this dramatic announcement riddled with
red meat of different kinds appealing to
fears about terrorism and so on and so
forth which are not unfounded fears but
he appeals to them in an irrational way
which is not actually dramatic in the
sense that he wanted it to be it's just
horrible
it's a horrible idea he's done this
before prior elections it unfortunately
does have an effect in the same way that
here in the United States sometimes
you'll see Republicans before an
election pull national security games oh
we've got a new recording from Osama bin
Laden remember that very similar dynamic
being employed in Israeli politics so
let's hope that he's voted out then
maybe if Donald Trump is also voted out
we can make some progress towards an
israeli-palestinian peace agreement the
parameters of which as I see them I've
laid out many times on the program but
again it is also more than just removing
Benjamin Netanyahu as I've talked about
before there is much more to it
including having Donald Trump a Benjamin
Netanyahu sycophant in the White House
in the United States
now one impediment that I've talked
about many times is not the annexation
specifically but settlements and the way
that this always works with these
annexations is Israel says you know we
need to create a defensive buffer
between Palestinian territory and
Israeli territory so we need this little
stretch of land here it's just a small
stretch of land they take it and then
settlers go into those buffer zones
which moves the perimeter at which yet
another buffer zone is supposedly needed
which justifies or at least creates the
pretext for Benjamin Netanyahu to again
say listen we've got to have a
protective buffer in now this new line
that has
drawn the settlements have to stop there
one of the biggest impediments to peace
big picture and I know you all know this
a ton of stuff has to change it is not
just Israeli policy that has to change
on the Palestinian side there is a long
list of policies and people and
practices and status quo that will never
lead to peace and I've been clear about
it I've not been shy about saying that
but this game that Benjamin Netanyahu is
playing is completely backwards
so let's hope that the promise of this
dramatic annexation of more West Bank
land ends up being nothing more than a
late a naked election electioneering
attempt and that Benjamin Netanyahu will
lose and thus not even have the chance
to make good on this promise because it
will only lead to more of the same and
more of what we've been seeing under
this guise numerous administration's
over the years